mr. Baker you obviously play a lot of
video games yourself yeah we were having
a bit of a chinwag before we went live
here about why you've been playing one
of your kind of top games of this year
bin so it's you know it's been a weird
year because you know we were promised
all the you know the the coming of the
console we're coming and invariably
you know because you have so much
potential in those things you also can
almost over develop sometimes or you
know expectations are so high that we've
seen every game like 2015 games are
going to be the best 2014 games because
they're just there was so many that got
pushed yeah and so it was actually kind
of cool for me because normally it's
like especially November and this
November has been crazy - there's like
you know six games that are released in
the last two weeks but it really kind of
gave me a chance to really focus in on
one game as opposed to playing it for a
little bit and then another game comes
out I feel like I have to get into that
and so I kind of have like these I'm
like the girl in the signs when those
like these all these half-drunken you
know cups of water everywhere but this
really got to give me the chance to we
started off a second son I think second
son was a phenomenal task and a lot of
fun great replayability because you're
going to either go blue or red and most
people did it in that chance you could
go play good then play it evil I had a
lot of fun with that and had one of the
best DLCs with with first light with the
fetch character played by Laura Bailey
and then I was really happy with it was
like a great deal seer because some of
things so many people were focusing on
pushing their next-gen consoles or
actual titles to the next year you
played in lost applause yeah do left
behind was fantastic it was just it was
so good and in some ways it was not
better than the last of us but it was it
was great because it was just such a
condensed story that fit in perfectly
with the rest of the narrative that even
if you hadn't played the main campaign
and the main story then you could jump
into there and would make you it made to
me have the the main game have more
weight to it because of some stuff that
plays in because essentially it's a
prequel so that was that was you know
two fantastic ways to start off the year
and I loved playing the remastered
version to see the last of us being you
know 60 frames 1080p whatever but it
wasn't just this cosmic
thing there was so much of that world
and so much other experience that was
made up of the environment and I spent
more time just exploring more than I
ever had before
and it had been like six months or eight
months that I played it last so you got
to come back and actually got be
surprised and forget some things and you
said you were playing GTA five as well
um we played honestly I think GTA 5 had
one of the best we just started the
remastered which is if you if you
haven't transferred if I played under a
profile underneath my account right so I
lost everything when you did the
transfer because you can't transfer your
proof right I'm gonna transfer your
account so everything that I leveled up
all the money that I had where you know
my safe house and everything else gone
and so that kind of sucks but how much
time did you put into the previous ten
Oh soul MIDI and like I mean I had
Millions
I was a mogul in that town um it was
boring then he needed to star first I
did but there's so many things that I
forget like I jumped online with my mate
so we started playing and they're like
all right let's get up here we're gonna
you know parachute over forts and kudo
and so i jump out of the plane like
everybody else realize no it's a wife
myself just do this thing don't wait up
have you done that in the first person
yet yes a play that the skydiving and
first person is absolutely terrifying AB
count terrified you can't see anything
it's it's almost impossible but I think
GTA had some of the best I was you know
multiplayer can go either way on a lot
of times I'm a really a story guy I want
a good campaign but in some ways I felt
that the the multiplayer experience was
it was even more incredible than the
single-player experience just even from
like a systemic developer standpoint to
have two independent assets working in
concert together an online space is just
that that's a tremendous feat so I
really give it to rock star from the
three games you were mentioning it
sounds like open world or at least like
universes that are believable are kind
of important to you yeah I want I want
to be grounded I want it if don't just
give me a multiplayer experience I gotta
be honest with you the titanfall um I
think you know obviously we've got the
the legacy of Call of Duty coming into
that and trying to go bigger and better
but but really you know I want to know
what the world is and I want to
experience I like
through a campaign and going I can't
wait to play this map you know in
multiplayer it's gonna be so cool I hope
they do this this level as something in
multiplayer but to be completely honest
with you and I'm gonna sound totally
biased but I think what I've put the
most amount of time in oh here we go
with shadow of Mordor when we when we
went to e3
you always hoped your going to make a
good game and while we're making the
game you know monolith is making the
game so a lot of times it's theater of
the mind we have no idea what things are
going to look like it's like we can
describe it to you and we can give you
like a grayscale model but we're
building it right now so this actually
exists and so it's like Christmas
morning every time I get a game because
I get to finally see I never get spoiled
for my own games because every time
invariably when I actually sit down and
play on my Oh
so that's what it looked like but I when
we went to e3 and the most brilliant
idiot stroke of genius that they had was
actually run live code of the Nemesis
system on the floor in front of people
which I mean huge margin of error it
could have gone horribly wrong and
everybody walked out and I saw so many
people that literally got right back in
queue to watch it again because they
wanted to see what would happen the next
time and so it made me super excited
about anyone actually sat down and
played I there were there was some
sleepless nights man and again me my
friends jumped on and played and I loved
the the fact that you could have
vendetta missions like you know hey
travis willingham just died he got his
you know head cut off by you know work
the the the gallbladder or whatever the
goal bladder i'm like it's in the game
my bad guys gonna die and and i'll say
this guy then we got to move on but my
favorite thing is when you start off and
i would even like text people from the
team like Ethan dude help me what do I
gotta do is I dude run that's what you
have to do when you first start off you
just run and you're just I'm a [ __ ] and
then you level up and you get better and
stronger and faster and you know the
first time I walked into a stronghold
and an orc stronghold I was like oh
there's ten people you know and you hear
that that horn blow and you're like this
is my death ya get me back and you watch
one guy go from level two to level 12
and now he's a captain they be a war
chief and like because he killed you one
time
and it gets so frustrating but then when
you finally level up there's such a
rewarding like satiating significant
power that comes from what you walk into
that strong holding you here mm-hmm and
you just go come alive it Breo you stand
there and you just become a badass so
it's it that was to me one of the most
rewarding addictive it's a time vampire
I mean I can just get lost for hours in
there I think I've put over 200 hours
Oman all right yes so I will be talking
more about a shot of Mordor on its dad
DLC with Michael to plan for monolith
who's gonna come on in just a second